we don't ask for a lot here at tv sins i
mean if there's one thing people say
about us it's so we're super easy going
and consider it but do you really expect
us not to mention how unevenly you're
wearing these [ __ ] bracelets right
now this show makes it seem so easy to
make a glass sing like this but every
time i try to do it i just get wet
fingers why is [ __ ] so hard and it's
called [ __ ] right
glass holes also taking your love of
annie linux many many literal steps too
far i'll take it over previously on but
after this intro i'm seriously going to
struggle to concentrate on anything
other than ethan hawke's feet and i
already lose my thursdays to that i mean
he'd love to get out there but it's a
bit hard with one fin
yes because the world is rife with fully
finned fish jumping free of their
perspex prisons and living their best
lives for approximately 30 seconds until
they drown in oxygen still selling the
old brushes and brooms right
right in front of my entrance well yeah
because you refuse to acknowledge that
he also sells a single rake no wonder
the guy never leaves also let's go ahead
and address the dick van dyke shaped
elephant in the room that's oscar's
british accent sure it might be a
purposeful character thing but i've
heard some people say it's good and i've
heard some people say it's bad so i went
straight to my friend from england to
see what he thought and he said it's
rubbish that means trash in england ease
so how could i not sin it this student
treats a museum display as her own
personal rubbish bin and the only
consequence she faces for a pyramid
scheme is to be educated do you want in
title dance this is how you get entitled
ants if this is some weird audition to
tour guide here the answer is still no
right because who'd want a tour guide
that knows what they're talking about
tour guides just need to be able to know
how to point the way to the gift shop
and completely ignore my question about
if impressionists were sellouts because
they only did it for the monet everyone
knows this not telling the couple whose
picture you're talking about the
terrible backlighting problem in the
shot obviously can't have anchor
restraints on my bed can i
that's a definition of a red flag isn't
it i mean it's kind of a gray area
actually presumably the tape's there to
show if mark left his apartment in his
sleep but if sleep steven has the
awareness to unbolt the door and walk
somewhere wouldn't it be safe to assume
that he also has the awareness to
re-tape the door and replace any
displaced sand hello and welcome to
staying awake
let's start with trying to solve a
puzzle or let's start with not being in
the place where sleep happens surrender
the body to mark my name is not mark in
this scene
the idiot's in control the first
wednesday of november every four years
without fail don't just stand there run
midnight venom so hard that i'm have
expecting oscar isaac to find a lobster
tank to climb into any second now when
someone tells me they don't believe
we're living in a simulation i think i
should just tell them that both oscar
isaac and ethan hawk are in the same
marvel tv show there is not a believable
world where this seems possible so i'm
sending whoever wrote this simulation
for making it a little too obvious but
the scales see everything perhaps it's
something that lies ahead as the dead
for know its society here minority
reports this poor woman i have to ask
two questions first why would anyone
volunteer to do this when the outcome is
at best being told you have a good
person's face and the other choice is to
die on the spot for crimes you may not
have even committed yet and two how
great was that dead for knoweth society
joke i mean come on
dear god did he just turn that lady into
a raisin my childhood fear of the raisin
bran sun mascot turning people into
raisins is flooding back into my mind
two scoops do i have a meat
oh
pollux funny yes but what about the guy
who's still standing in stephen neal's
how do you know it wasn't him i'm trying
to get back home back to london
london if you were trying to find your
way home don't you think you'd be moving
away from the crowd or running down the
street to get yourself away from the bad
guys why are protagonists always drawn
to the danger plot magnets how do they
work so strange moon knight upgrades so
hard that i'm half expecting oscar isaac
to find a kitchen knife and bifurcate
someone's face with it beating six
people bloody in front of a child do you
think mark looked back at the kid and
said want to see something cool before
spiking the skull of a goon onto the
cobblestone right in front of her eyes i
mean if we're destroying innocence we
might as well be thorough geez marvel
you cut that action scene to death so
much that i have no clue what even
happened here oh god steven's immediate
reaction isn't core blimey guff what
happened to me old meat hook
what is his order of cupcakes doing in
the middle console of the truck you look
like you have plenty of room back there
which means the truck driver was
planning on eating an order ah
i knew it wasn't there some sort of
horror movie where there was this log
truck that resulted in a bunch of deaths
i can't remember what it was called but
i'm just saying this episode keeps
emulating movie after movie and i'm just
wondering what the final destination is
for all these rip-offs just a note on
human psychology if you were to pass out
and wake up driving a vehicle backward
you wouldn't have time to process that
consciously before your brain had
already instantly been overwhelmed and
shut down your motor functions my point
is this moment would not result in an
adjustment period it would result in a
steven is instantly dead and mangled at
the bottom of a ravine period
deus ex lagena stephen wakes up here and
is eventually relieved to learn it was
all a dream accepted wasn't a dream at
all so where did the injury on steven's
hand go and why isn't his jaw causing
him all sorts of michael caine
there's no way he spotted that fish was
a discount gus from that distance as it
was swimming around the tank you think
you can do these things but you just
can't stevo today what do you see i see
two fins yeah sorry show completely
ignores the caudal pictorial dorsal and
anal fins that's right goldfish have
anal fins
look as i said they've all got two fins
not finding nemo hunt peck phone control
for the love of efficiency people the
verizon gods gave you thumbs for a
reason use them i ate steak by myself
thanks two days ago if steven hasn't
been in touch with unnamed love interest
how did he even know where to go for the
date was best steakhouse in town really
enough to go on also does she not have
his number does he not have a single
voicemail or pissed off message from her
i'll put you for well done scene does
not contain a
what is with this accent right ironic
that being knighted makes you lose your
english accent
steven
stop looking i've put it off as long as
possible but this show is fresh
interesting quirky spooky and different
than anything the mcu has ever done and
i can feel my mirror mark taking over
just to take us in off stealing your
spooking techniques from library
haunting ghosts in the 80s for some
inexplicable reason steven chooses the
slowly descending metal box with only
one exit instead of the stairs as his
method of escape also i wouldn't take
this lift even if my life wasn't in
danger this thing looks like it hasn't
been touched by an engineer in decades
has witnessed multiple homicides and is
on the cdc shortlist of locations likely
to start the next pandemic oh my god
he's real why was he hanging out on the
same bus as steven he knows where steven
works so it's not like he needs to
follow him who takes the bus when they
don't even need to i'm just watching
lots of videos again wait is this all jb
does steven can't see his screen so
otter video seemed like a pretty wild
guess unless this is something jb is
famous for what's a big deal anyway
they're just furry little water oh look
at him cuddling his traffic cone
consider this had um had been free
she would have prevented hitler in the
destruction he wrote using her powers to
stop hitler cliche by even her own
avatar avatars blue people love that
film by avatar you mean that i mean
anime starting with the blue people
instead of the greatest show in the
history of nickelodeon i saw you kill
that woman in the alps it's been three
days and you still haven't reported this
to the law i mean not that the police in
this universe would believe a story of
discount kevin bacon turning people into
raisins somewhere in europe but it's
worth a try how exactly did he clear out
this entire room for this moment wasn't
this all taking place in the heart of
the day when the show needs it later
people will interrupt but the crowds are
being super polite now to avoid spoiling
the tension at the wrong time
[Music]
hello donna inspecting the weird noises
in your museum when you know where is
going down instead of getting the hell
out before the moon night at the
museuming can begin this metaphysical
egyptian demon ghost dog thing is toying
with stephen when in a few minutes he
will pounce the [ __ ] out of him why
this metaphysical egyptian demon ghost
dog thing is tricked by throwing a bag
so maybe it's just not all that smart
which makes it hard to care
episode does not contain a blip
reference
the thing is bob
it's not that i'm lazy it's that i just
don't care
and i'm gonna keep doing a boat because
they make me feel good it's not like
there's anything in there what the [ __ ]
you say to me a little
i've been good
my entire life but you one crazy ass
[ __ ]
london
don't know what i'm saying like that you
sound like you're from london
that's so strange sorry
the pen
that i hold in my hand
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
take this downstairs can't be bothered
you're not worth the trouble it would
take to hit you donna
i'm the captain now
stupid dog you made me look bad